one of our favorites kind enough to call
in every single week uh
to help us get through the nfl weeks
without games
um and uh here he is back again uh in
the bye week prior to super bowl 55
from good morning football and his
podcast
very popular podcast on the ringer in
spotify is back after hiatus with his
guest viggo mortensen
uh ten questions with kyle brent we have
kyle brent back here on the show how are
you sir
great to be here rich i was listening
and enjoying the
the highlight package that you just
played during the rich eisen show and i
i i heard boomer in there did wasn't
chris berman off the start of that he
was
boomer was part of our guest that week
it makes me so nostalgic it takes me
right back
and it's what you know over the last two
years even the last couple of weeks
there's been so much talk of course rich
about eric bienemy the great chief
doctor
coordinator and every single time i hear
the name eric the enemy i think of
boomers saying eric's sleeping with the
enemy
every time we were talking about that
just earlier this week kyle that's why
we're
we're you know we're we're of like mind
here uh also some of his
we we mentioned they pictured jim two
silhouettes on de shays we just
mentioned
the price is right joe actual retail
price was my one of my favorite
nicknames
burt beholm bly 11 is uh a great one
and he gave me two when i was at uh espn
uh he gave me rich kaleidoscope eisen
which was a beatles reference
um uh but my favorite one uh he went kim
karnes as he said to me is he gave it to
me rich
betty davis eisen
see i don't even get some of them i
thought he would have gone rich
bad moon eisen but that was andre that
was for andre
horizon correct he doesn't really try to
repeat uh
when he came on several years ago uh
chris crocodile brockman
was your nickname correct or or brockman
turner over
that's right chris brown
yeah i um i remember being in about i
don't know in high school or something
and i was a big fan of
jeff brown paper bagwell um but there's
just so many listen
the same thing i said about the enemy
with berman i'm not exaggerating when i
say this rich
when i'm not sleeping well or i'm
stressed or something every time
in the middle of the night that i stir
in bed and flip my pillow over to the
other side
i think of stu scott i mean every time
every time those lines stick with me
they're iconic and i get nostalgic when
i think about them me too
kyle brandt here on the rich eisen show
okay what's what have you guys been
talking about in the bye week here
kyle what do you got is it aaron rodgers
talk what's been
what's been the conversation aaron
rodgers and it's just mostly
this this unbelievable brady versus
mahomes match-up
um i volunteered the question today
things can get misconstrued and when you
people think you're saying as an opinion
yes i just offered the question
yes i said is this is this the best
quarterback matchup in the super bowl
that we've seen now
that can go a lot away there's some
great ones we had a way versus far
we had peyton versus breeze that there's
troy aikman jim kelly there's been some
great ones roethlisberger rogers
it's tough to beat this one just because
of the stakes the story lines
all the metaphors um we're talking a lot
about that and i've been following some
of your comments rich
that i think are timely inappropriate
about brady in that it's it's almost
this exercise and fighting exhaustion
and trying to find
ways to shower this man with the praise
that he deserves right
and i the only way that i found is is
this is that
people are saying you know he's the goat
and mahomes is the next coming i say
hold on a second
pastor mahomes may very well be the
football jesus he may end up being the
best player ever however
he is in brady's zip code if you tell as
much as we expect from a home and how
great his career is going to be
do we really expect that he will be
starting
in the super bowl for super bowl
73 super 73 because that is 18 years
from now
and that is the equivalent of what tom
brady is doing and in the year 2039
if patrick mahomes is starting the super
bowl for a new team by the way that he's
just been with for one year
that will be the equivalent 73. and we
we've
we've gate we game this out all the time
too kyle because
we try where as all of us you me
anybody who does this for a living and
we're so fortunate to do for a living
trying to lend perspective as to what
brady's doing and how we may never
see it again and extrapolating out you
know again brady
uh making it to 14 championship games
and that mahomes would have to
in order to make the super bowl um you
know
win this second one or the you know
third one of his career
and then make the super bowl eight more
times to match what brady's done
and and then make you know 11 more
championship game
weekends right and and so on and so
forth but the truth is
the truth truly is uh you know and and
john wall she was the father of sports
center in the
back in the day and was there when i was
there he hated the on pace to
conversation because it just does you
can't assume
in the same way that you know frank
reich had kicked the field goal early on
in the first playoff game of the year
how that would have actually manifested
in the fourth quarter
everyone would have operated differently
if it was a tie score as opposed to
missing those three points and so on and
so forth you can't really say on pace
too
uh accurately that said
you have to look at what's already
happened and just like
brady okay mahomes saddest first year he
did wet his beak a little bit
the week 17 start brady didn't in 2000.
and then
in 2018 2019 2020 he made the afc
championship game all three years
in brady's next three years he made the
afc championship game
twice because he won the super bowl
twice which is what mahomes can do
by winning this super bowl but beating
brady by a year
going back to back for it he would be
better it's a it would be a better
four year start than brady
and brady can personally if he wants to
just snuff it out
right here right now he could beat
mahomes and kind of put even more
distance between him and the kid that's
on pace
uh that's a fact about this coming super
bowl
it's fascinating we lay it out it almost
rich has this sort of um
disappearing polaroid of marty mcfly's
feeling to it
like where brady can affect his own
future
he can punch him out like biff he could
punch him out you know he could punch
biff out or he could just you know
not you know it's it's that is correct
that is a way to look at it
yeah and it's it's mahomes is like
holding the lombardy and brady comes up
says hey you
get your damn hands off him and changes
everything
it is wild when you look nice because 50
years from now we look back in the
home's careers like brady put a stop to
it
and the whole on pace conversation
changed i also think that
you know when you have these these sort
of arguments the
whether you do the goat thing again
there's always this army
in this this this joe montana army
and i totally respected i was joe
montana for halloween when i was in
sixth grade i
loved him i loved everything about him
and you know their their ammunition is
potent
they say look joe never lost the super
bowl
joe never threw an interception in the
super bowl he's the greatest and
my response now to that is like well you
know if joe had gotten to
ten of them he probably would have lost
a few and i guarantee would have thrown
some interceptions so i respect the
clean four that he played
but it's it's not even in the same
vicinity anymore i don't even think
we're in the same area code no we're not
the conversation's over
it's over and it doesn't matter if brady
wins or loses two sundays from now
and if he does win then he does put more
distance between him and mahomes we
assume is going to come the closest
because he's not only that talented
he's got the coach that's not going
anywhere and he's got some of his
weapons
that aren't going anywhere they're
they're signed and locked
and um so we're assuming mahomes is the
one that can get closest
because he's already off to a better
start i mean mahomes has not missed the
playoffs in his first four years brady
did
in between his first two super bowls he
missed the playoffs in 2002.
you know mahomes can go back to back in
his first four years which brady
never did and mahomes is more
you know he he's he's you could say he's
more athletically gifted which is
something i think even brady in his
heart of hearts you know on sodium
pentathol hooked up to that
with nobody else around might actually
even admit you know
and so that's part of this that years
from now
we're assuming we're not going to see it
again next year because we could but
years from now like 10 15 years around
when god
bless it we're all knock on wood talking
about a super bowl 70 remember that time
when brady mahomes played each other you
know i mean that's
you know that's that's what's at stake
that's what's in
in front of us and it is pretty cool it
really is it's really cool
um i think we got it right too you know
this final four had a feeling uh of four
one seeds in the ncaa tournament like we
got the
the four best teams and i think we got
the best two teams i mean i think the
packers would have gotten destroyed by
the mahomes offense
i don't think the bills are quite ready
we got these two we had a conversation
this morning
about okay so you got the young really
really good one then you got the
greatest of all time
but let's look at this let's say that
your team is down five points with a
minute and a half to go and you got to
go 80 yards
do you want to hand the ball to mahomes
or do you want to hand it to brady
and we all kind of disagreed on it um
because listen as great as brady's done
some very high profile let downs that
he's had in those super bowls
you know he's he's the one who got
stripped by brandon graham against the
eagles he's the one who lost two times
to the giants and did not have his best
games and
sure that comes with going there a lot
eventually gonna mess up but i just it's
mahomes just
he doesn't lose he doesn't make the huge
mistake
and i i was one of the people at the
table said as much as i respect brady if
i play a game this weekend i'm giving it
to my homes
because rich don't you think this this
whole vibe of this super bowl is
how can you bet against tom brady and
then you say well hold on
how can you bet against patrick mahomes
you can't bet against either of these
yeah and that said though the time that
they have faced in the playoffs before
brady did get him
and then you are right though i know you
used it as kind of a
for the lack of but a phrase throwaway
line but you know if if
if montana had six more appearances in
the super bowl he might have had
his brendan graham strap strips a moment
you know what i mean like that that
could have happened
i just think that you know i'm beginning
to lean on it right now i'm thinking
about it
uh when i'm behind the wheel of a car
knowing i'm going to have to put my
marker down at some point
that that i don't know if it's going to
be that close
you know what i mean like it was close
in the final three quarters in the first
uh go round between these two but man oh
man oh man
you know uh the chiefs might be too far
in front for any brady comeback to
materialize
when it all comes down to it you know
and i know i chose the bills over the
chiefs to win it because i just thought
maybe mahomes might not be a hundred
percent
but he's on i mean like honestly he he
showed up in the fc
uh championship game i've never seen
anybody turn
turf toe into uh jordan's flu you know
what i mean like i've never seen that
before
um but i haven't either you know that
the way this chief team works rich is
someone who also picked the bills
you know when i knew the bills were
screwed in that game when they when they
had no chance
when they went up nine to nothing that's
when i knew the game was over it's over
because there's this thing with the
chiefs where it's like
don't piss them off like you gotta kind
of sneak up on them
and you know they have the must punt
don't punch that in for a touchdown
you're gonna wake the dragon kick the
field goal there and i don't feel like
the bills knew it because they scored
the touchdown
and missed the extra point like as if a
way to say i'm sorry to the football
guys it was too late when they went up
nine to nothing it was over there's
something about this chiefs team
where they almost like getting down
early and then they they just unleash
hell
with the full dracaris and i bear that
in mind in the super bowl
if brady goes down the field up seven
nothing i bet the bucks are screwed
we'll see how that all plays out kyle
brandt here uh on the rich eyes and
shout out kyle just bet the over like
don't even worry about taking brady or
mahomes you know what i mean
absolutely life's too short to go under
is that leave him alone he's an nfl guy
leave him alone chris don't talk though
nfl rich don't put him don't yeah i know
i know they had me do like a read for
caesar's rewards
where you give away prizes for guessing
like flat out prop bets
yeah i'm like i'm like wow this is uh
i've never had this
free weekends coming up yeah all right
so hey
uh kyle so viggo mortensen is your guest
as your
your pod is back in action correct
that's what you got
back how cool is that somewhat reclusive
eagle mortenson who was
unbelievably spectacular um two things
we i put him through sort of a
tournament style who you got
um his character aragorn from the lord
of the rings trilogy in a straight up
sword fight versus
the likes of maximus william wallace jon
snow
okay and he ran through them all and it
has people foaming at the mouth with
takes about who's the best swordsman
but rich here's the here's the best way
i can explain how interesting vigo
mortensen is as a person
he tells all the stories about eastern
promises history of violence lord of the
rings all these other movies has been
like crimson tide and gi jane and
young guns too for years and yet he has
this story in his pocket that he doesn't
even bring out we're talking about
arcade games we got on this topic and he
says you know the only time i've played
an arcade game was i was playing
centipede
back in the day in 1980 because i was uh
volunteering at the 1980
winter olympics and i said well hold on
like you were in like past you were
there for that
for that when that game happened the
miracle on ice oh yeah i was at that
game
as a vigo you were at the us versus the
soviets game in the arena
he said yeah i was friends with the
hockey team from finland and uh
beforehand we we drank a bunch of
finland vodka and got really drunk and
we went to the game
and he proceeds to tell a whole story of
what it was like in the arena that day
and how the soviets were so breathtaking
but the americans
and he was right up against the glass
it's the craziest get out of here
viggo mortensen's pounding on the glass
is you know jack o'callaghan's and
grinding in the corner and stuff like
that is what you're saying yes
yeah he's there and he has whole takes
on it and
i mean i didn't he used to go to buffalo
bills games during the oj
era because he was living in that part
of new york and he's got these crazy
really
cool vintage sports stories including
being at the most triumphant american
sporting mom in the last 50 years it was
it's an awesome awesome session wow and
well we are we we've got him teed up for
next tuesday
so um you've given me some i guess this
is like a pre-interview through kyle
brown and then
everybody run with it richie check it
out very anecdotal check it out on on
where all podcasts are acquired kyle
brandt uh the ringer and spotify
uh ten questions with kyle brad you know
before i let you go
how old are your children how old are
they i have a seven-year-old son and a
four-year-old daughter okay so you're
not
cut you're you know you're not really
where i'm at just yet
because i was talking earlier before 12
9 and 7
trying to get them all to choose the
same movie i tried to get them to see
miracle
and again you bringing up you know herb
brooks and
you know channeling him on good morning
football and
all of that to put in my mind like maybe
i should start watching miracle with my
kids that really is the way that this
all worked
and i could not get them to watch it um
first i had to give i had to give before
i received
from them so my give was allowing them
to
say you know saying yes the green light
the viewing of the war with grandpa
um yes and it dawned on me in the middle
of watching this
that this is the first de niro movie my
children have ever seen
oh no
yeah and it's the first time they've
ever seen christopher walken and cheech
marin and jane seymour
and i'm like wait till you see the deer
hunter up and smoke and live and let die
you know and they're like looking at me
like what the hell are you saying dad
and i'm like
i i i it was really jarring
to say the least kyle yeah so
raging bull be damned taxi driver it was
the war
wait is it the war with grandpa is the
name of the system is the name of the
film
yes that de niro said yes to and at one
point
you know my wife said not you know
she sees how i'm not handling this very
well
susie says to me you know without really
saying it too loud for the kids to hear
she goes why would deniro do this
and i gave the money symbol to her you
know
that's it you know i guess grandpa
needed a new pair of shoes or something
you know
robert de niro i i think this would be
the same answer to the question of why
did he do a rocky and bullwinkle
live-action film
there's been a moment here where bob de
niro said you know what i'm a legend i'm
going to make whatever the hell i want
to let's go
and and i respect them for it richards
and i'm reminded of something in the nfl
world with exactly what you're talking
about
uh drew brees when you inevitably talk
to him the next time asking about this
because he goes on instagram and he post
pictures with his children
you know brees family movie night yeah
and he's got these boys watching
hoosiers uh remember the titans rocky
one rocky one which is rock watch for an
adult even sometimes and let alone a kid
somehow the breeze children will sit for
these movies
crazy with envy wow no doubt about it
no how do you do that i can't get my kid
to watch five minutes of anything with
any substance and he's got them watching
uh gene hackman measuring the the how
high the hoop is for hickory high and
they're
sitting there and learning it it's
bailing and kaelin and all
of them they're just killed it makes me
so angry i know you're supposed to sit
there and say how sweet is this but if
you have your own children
you can't pull it off even though i did
get him to watch hoosiers but i did have
to like
stop it a few times and say can we
please watch this this is a big moment
when they're measuring the rim to the
floor it's big for your dad it's big for
you you don't understand it
even though you know like and and and
they have seen remember the titans but
there's no chance rocky won there's just
not a chance in this green earth but god
no
i mean it's slow that rocky was a slow
burn and they're ice skating
interminably two hours we're getting
meat and everything i watched
that rich you'd have to watch it you
know old grandpa dirty grandpa
he was great as a grandfather i mean
deniro was terrific it's just you know
oh my god
kyle thank you for the call appreciate
it let's chat again next week for the
big game it's always a blast no one has
more fun than you guys thanks richard
right back at you
buddy that's and that's the guy who has
fun every day on good morning football
we'll take the compliment we'll take it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here